qui est ce personnage étonnant nommé
nicholas vie dean et qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire assez assez
rocambolesque du trésor de l'armé
blanche robert laffont vous qualité les
souvenirs de nicholas feeling jour
d'abord vous nous racontiez dans quelles
circonstances assez curieuse aussi
curieuse que le personnage qui est à
votre gauche
dans quelles circonstances j'ai fait sa
connaissance eh bien j'ai reçu un jour
une lettre et j'en reçois beaucoup mon
courrier depuis que j'ai publié
papillons des gens qui me disent j'ai
vécu des aventures extraordinaires et
les aventures sont de toute façon
beaucoup plus intéressante que celle que
vous avez publié par conséquent si vous
me faites confiance vous verrez ce que
vous verrez et j'ai ouvert ce jour là
mon courrier j'ai vu une lettre à peu
près semblable mais qui avait une fin
assez différente et cette fin était la
suivante
ce correspondant me disait de toute
façon je peux pas venir vous voir je
suis dans une situation difficile
alors si vous voulez me voir mais tu es
une annonce dans france soir
monsieur georges est priée de téléphoner
et ça ça m'a drôlement intrigué parce
que c'était un première fois qu'un
auteur demandé de mettre une annonce
dans france soir
alors bon je dis je vais mettre une
annonce en france soir et j'ai reçu un
coup de téléphone c'est monsieur georges
qui m'ont téléphoné et j'ai pris rendez
vous avec lui et c'était nicholas médine
qui me raconter une aventure absolument
rocambolesque
et là quelle a été votre premier
sentiment en écoutant le récit de ses
aventures qui sont de fait assez
rocambolesques et bah quand j'ai voulu
rentrer ce grand kozak ça m'a
impressionné
et tout ce qui m'a dit
m'a paru assez fascinant parce que tout
ce qui est des histoires l'armé blanche
la retraite des troupes blanche russe
et puis ensuite sa vie et puis et puis
cette fameuse histoire du trésor ça m'a
absolument c'était une histoire
romanesque des doutes quand même et eu
des doutes mais nous avons contrôlé nous
avons contrôlé ce qu'ils nous disaient
est ce qu'ils ne faisaient correspondait
à nous avons fait quelques enquêtes
il avait une vie en effet qui
corresponde à ce qu'ils disaient avec
des trous et avec au moment des moments
de grand c'est grand faste et c'est
moment d'en face on pouvait
difficilement les expliquer si on ne
compte on ne vais pas la clé de la
ventura la clé de l'aventuré c'est la
clé du trésor et ce qui m'a déterminé
c'est lorsqu'il m'a dit écoutez on loue
ayotte
on part en bulgarie et on va trouver le
trésor alors là j'ai un cas de
conscience terrible parce que je pouvais
arriver avec un trésor et m'arrêter de
fer d'édition en tout cas robert laffont
où il ya un reproche qu'on nous fera pas
à propos de nicolas ce feeling c'est le
reproche que certains que certains vous
ont fait à propos de papillons à savoir
est-ce que papillon a écrit son livre
non elle n'a pas écrit ici là écrit
ainsi de suite ce qui est sûr c'est que
nicholas vide il l'a écrit parce qu'il
faut bien reconnaître que vous gagnez
certain que nicholas feeling lui ce
livre est écrit à la cosaque et c'est
normal puisque nicolas ce vide est un
officier kozak 1 mètre 90 votre père
faisait d'eux mais votre grand-père 2010
note un peu lumineux de la famille enfin
quand même à mettre 90 secondes
alors vous quand éclate la la révolution
russe ensuite la guerre civile vous êtes
évidemment du côté des blancs ça c'est
une tradition familiale
vous tuez un grand nombre de rouge vous
même vous échappé par miracle plusieurs
fois à la mort et puis vous perdez la
guerre civile
et vous voilà un jour en bulgarie avec
d'autres officiers russes blancs et avec
aussi un 13 heures le trésor de l'armé
blanche qu'est ce que c'est que ce 13
heures 13 heures de quoi
de quoi s'agit-il d'un jouet
actuellement d'abord ils avaient lancé
vingt caisses il y avait donc médias il
y avait bien il y avait là lors katyn
les diamants les actions l'argent que je
n'allais pas trop ce qui importe à de la
russie a réquisitionné dans les banques
c'est donc valeur était un cas que sur
les airs de ses banquiers pour qu'ils ne
tombent pas dans la main et poursuivi
qu'on les a ramassés avec l'attention dé
créer un fonds de réserve mais je pense
par exemple à l'armé blanche qui était
là la russie donc il fallait avoir un
peu d'argent
voilà un récit vous en avez fait là ses
trésors en ce qui me concerne je pars
donc là notre tâche d'abord était de le
cacher parce que je réponde à un mollet
nous on était obligé par la situation
politique qui régnait alors un bulgarie
qui avait dirigé par michel symboliste
qui était qui était donc ce sens pas
qu'ils en ont peut être compris de
craindre qu'à un moment donné qui va
nous arrêter ce qui est arrivé derrière
et par notre réseau mais pour l'éviter
cela donc je n'aime pas trop ce qui nous
a ordonné de le cacher la ville avait
enfoui en fruits et je suis moment après
nous pendant les bulgares ont commencé à
arrêter là
un membre de notre organisation ce sont
des faits historiques
je n'ai pas trop ce qui était tirée par
la mise à disposition
on a arrêté je ne comptais pas le fameux
chenal du port sont pas des noms qui
nous sont très familiers il faut bien le
dire
en fait ce qui est sûr c'est que
finalement au bout de quelques mois vous
vous retrouvez être le seul survivant
pour jean par un peu par hasard qu'ils
savent où se cache le tout à l'heure
vous voilà en occident en exil en
occident en belgique en france et vous
n'avez qu'une hâte évidemment c'est de
retourner en bulgarie pour mettre au
jour le trésor et leur apporter alors
vous y allé plusieurs fois vous monter d
un des expéditions qui certains échouent
d'autres réussissent et lorsqu elles
réussissent vous en mettez plein les
poches et vous revenez en occident et
vous vivez il faut bien dire assez
fastueusement avec une toute petite
partie du trésor mais vous faites des
cadeaux je vous fait des dons si la
veille se charger lui même beaucoup mais
beaucoup parce que j'ai donc profité
personnellement je distribuais à gauche
à droite 1 prr à tout le monde de la
padanie pourquoi je voulais pas qu'on le
sache pas ce que c'est sur le poste d'où
ça vient surtout main soupçonné
d'ailleurs dans mon livre je raconte que
même rejoint soviétique
connaissant parfaitement à l'histoire de
ce trésor elle m'a donné même ordonné
lemera draps
il m'a promis de mettre des corps et
cela je suis passé soviétique
ces moments là bas montre enfin éclater
alors vous vivez des aventures aussi que
ça c'est extraordinaire
notamment vous êtes un moment directeur
d'une chorale cosaques et puis la guerre
éclair là je sais juste mais avec cet
argent la voix l'a fait chanter des
données d'un paquet des yeux son
directeur cemac la subventionner
beaucoup plus belles heures après la
guerre mais alors la guerre arrive et
puis le rideau de fer
alors fini les expéditions aventure
gardien alors vous essayez vous ne
pouvais plus aller en bulgarie bien sûr
que non alors c'est vous ne pouvez plus
vivre avec l'argent du trésor de l'armé
blanche et le trésor il est toujours là
bas enterré quelque part profondément en
bulgarie j'ajoute que vous soyez à 4,1
pour voir si ce teaser existe vraiment
parce que j'ai eu l'attention d'autres
régions une expédition geipel et loire
je trouvais que toute la quatre parties
sont intactes bon donc il est là bas ça
nous rassure un joli dans votre livre
cette phrase je me demande souvent
maintenant quand je pense à l'actuelle
union soviétique
si j'aurais fait la guerre civile en
sachant ce que mon pays allait devenir
voilà une phrase qui nous permet la
réconciliation non pas du tout pas du
tout ce que c'est un régime n'est ce pas
là qui va mettre en danger intérêts de
ma patrie
j'ai avant tout patriote us à lorient
nancy vous n'êtes pas trio non non non
je voyais en espagne bat d
des voyous pour ainsi dire pas venir
tout le monde n'est ce pas mon devoir de
prusse truc dan officie c'étaient des
combats très forts s'efface quand ce
dernier suit est parce que n'oubliez pas
cessible parce que faute me prend en
considération
j'espère comme il n'est pas absolument
étrangères moi ma nature à mes
convictions
cela laisse pas tout de même c'est un
régime qui fait énormément de choses
pour la russie d'un pays les très
pauvres qui est vrai qu'avec des
emprunts extérieurs intérieurs qu'ils
ont fait un puissance formidable ça ça
contre elle a déjà compris à moi un
patron propose enfin oui alors je suis
dit justement va pas parler du passé
quand même toute la soirée et il faut
quand même justement savoir qu'est ce
que nous allons faire de ceux de ce vol
vous êtes le seul à connaître
l'existence de ce trésor alors il faut
quand même le rendre il appartient au
peuple heureux et bien voilà la messe
pas donc je lance un appel aux grands
matches
c'est un appel que vous lancez aux
pharmaceutiques
alors je ne savais pas moi c'est vous
monsieur nicolas ce vide je lance un
appel au gouvernement soviétique et je
lui propose d'aller en personne en
bulgarie et d'indiquer la l'emplacement
du trésor car il est absolument
impossible d'indiquer ce placement sur
le papier toutefois j'irai là-bas à
certaines conditions que voici
premièrement les gouvernements
soviétique et bulgares s'engagent
formellement à me laisser repartir
immédiatement de bulgari dans le pays de
mon choix en occident deuxièmement
j'irais là accompagné par mon avocat et
par une personnalité de la presse
internationales acceptées par le
gouvernement soviétique et moi même
troisièmement en prenant en
considération que le trésor appartient
au peuple russe qui se trouvent dans en
union soviétique à l'étranger
c'est-à-dire les réfugiés n'ayant acquis
aucune autre nationalité
ce trésor doit être divisé en deux
parties égales une partir en union
soviétique
l'autre en france c'est mon avocat et la
personne désignée qui se chargeront de
compte du contrôle du partage et c'est
aussi ces personnes qui doivent
accompagner en avion le trésor en france
quatrièmement le trésor ne peut être
employé temps en union soviétique à
l'étranger
qu'exclusivement pour début
l'humanitaire cinquièmement en ce qui me
concerne je ne désire absolument rien
pour moi eh bien monsieur suis dit
j'espère que l'ambassadeur du rss à
paris monsieur tchervenkov dans son
poste qu'il transmettra à qui de droit
en tout cas merci davance si on retrouve
je suis le 13 heures j'ai près dans
d'aller là bas et quand goudron et lors
je signale que le livre de nicholas
bidean ne sera en vente que mercredi
prochain dans les librairies
c'est à dire après demain
[Musique]